[Music]
and find the bot news submitted by
Korean fried chicken whoa that's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] more than churches yo you
know what this soy is open you
everything you know what it is it's to
me American fried chickens here any
other fusion fried chicken is happy to
know barn
well he doesn't my thing it's just
different worlds I can't even put them
in the same category
first of all Korean fried chicken to me
is always only like the the wing kill
John taps yeah like small know we have
told what is that they we have our whole
fried chicken and we actually you'll get
the crisp from the batter or the flour
it's just the skin itself oh yeah I like
that kind that's called a royal old or
something right I guess I call it Tonga
I don't like it when it's too much skin
yeah like the batter I call it bone
saying I don't care about food you know
general just fried chicken yes food in
general [ __ ] about candy though I'm
[ __ ] always about two college
students developed a way to expose BOTS
and fake news accounts on Twitter we
need that [ __ ] cuz sometimes we were
reporting fake ass news and then later
we find out aha it was fake yeah hmm
fake news is so easily absorbed by
really dumb people it's crazy they just
don't they don't do the due diligence to
check important informations before they
take it and they tell somebody else even
real news thanks David he just said
sometimes you talk about fake yeah but
we are for entertainment so it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
everyone's watching this is like serious
yeah we're just like no sense news here
but it's actually an acronym for not
ever I just like
oh pretty [ __ ] good not every word
soon this is JK not every word serious I
like that put the whole teacher guys you
guys have a freak
thank you oh wow thanks nice Chinese of
you first let's read second one double
yeah yeah these two Bay Area college
students from Berkeley it's always the
Bay Area is it like babe BAE or like BAE
what where's the where's the Bay Area
yeah what's the no there's an area where
there's a lot of bay people no come on
that wasn't attempt doesn't at a joke
but I'm from the Bay Area we make that
Joe all the times old and played out all
you do have roasted her ass that's dope
there's the baby bad wind chill room
marketed [ __ ] it donald suck let's
continue they created this website
called bot check got me most flores all
smart as well as from extension yeah you
are position David I wasn't thinking
that I would said good on them what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you because they're
doing something with their life and your
we saying are you know there's two gay
guys that finally did something amazing
in this world and you can't give them
that credit way they're gay no where did
you get that from they're from San
Francisco and then we assume
intelligence with gay people all the
time so is what it is smart gay men come
from Silicon Valley in San Francisco at
that age 20 years old yeah well it's not
reported out there gates oh oh
irrelevant
it's very sorry to protesters from
Berkeley protesters yes I want to be
protesting there pearl protesters so
anyway their website got check got me
and they also have a Google Chrome
extension can tell you based on a set of
quick characteristics whether or not an
account that you're looking at is real
or it's a buck and so they've been able
to do this they only took them eight
weeks to complete this down for you and
this is really interesting because they
have contacted Twitter to be able to
like work with them so they can use this
tool and they could finally stop all
these like BOTS
happening on Twitter but for some reason
Twitter just hasn't gotten back to them
and they're just saying like
no because Twitter likes fake Twitter
screwing up these days it you know why
because a huge owner of Twitter is
Prince Alois and he recently got
incarcerated by his own government where
did you read in Sanna Twitter because it
could be fake I forgot okay I have a
question
someone might help me but why what's the
point of fake news it's because it's
spreading misinformation so like a lot
more saying like that's the the whole
fake news and fake accounts like from
Russia have you guys heard of the whole
thing happening right all farming yeah
these troll forms that they swayed the
election anything we got [ __ ] people
wrote Russian troll forms in our
comments and [ __ ] punk-ass [ __ ] no
these are all real they all really don't
like you you roasted me and now you
roasted Joe no no see it says you're
behind it aren't you
it's not it says and I saw site in in a
nice cold you know like I don't know I
caught you you [ __ ]
all right so I'm Trump and you're Putin
and you got your [ __ ] troll farmers
coming on to the JK channel cuz your cuz
you're Wong flow although you want to be
you and I Trump that's today it's
relevant I'm dropping your Putin you're
making your Putin there for friends who
could we cool we're friends but we're
frenemies because you got your troll
farm and you're bringing your TRO farm
fans I I do actually help you win so I
do think I guess lots are very
dangerously because like sometimes I'm
always thinking like there was a time
when if a crazy or whatever dumb person
somewhere in the United States had his
bad opinion of whatever dumb opinion
they were just confined to just their
own circle of friends now they can put
it on social media somewhere and then
get validation yeah oh this is a
thousands of people and if those people
are fake you know like then they're
getting like they're they're getting
their story they're creating a buzz or
making their story viral from all these
fake people that don't actually agree
but like it just it's out there so it's
actually like amplifying like a lot of
idiocy right was before it was like some
guys just in it's like on his portion
like
and that was it and that's where it
stops yeah yeah because they were called
the village idiot it was stupid they're
connecting all the [ __ ] porch idiots
yeah together all together and they're
on the same wavelength
yeah and they're getting together and
they're protesting yeah on both sides
more numbers behind it what what um have
you guys ever like actually found like
like what do BOTS look like especially
those sexual ones well those are easy
because it like those have like weird
links in like weird words but I always
have this website here they're able to
detect it because of the certain
characteristics which for example like
this one Twitter account is tweeting out
multiple tweets within like a really
short span like no human is gonna do
that so then that's like a clear sign no
sometimes I go on a Twitter rampage and
then they'll tweet out links yeah that
then then once you actually track where
the links go
it's like connected to Russia somehow so
that's what they're looking into right
now in session
I wish they did that on YouTube with
like dumb comments on YouTube come on
Russia just stick to porn do you do that
so well he's not known for is their
second best you know
yeah next baka and then caviar vodka
sturgeon meat and porn star there's a
big fish that looks like a alligator
[Laughter]
accuracy rate and that number keeps
getting better
Wow I just blew up I feel so bad for
those seven point or sorry six point
five percent that's like it's not me I'm
real but at the same time if you're a
real person you're twenty forty to the
tweeting forty I need a life yeah then
you should be shut down anyways that's
true that's that go step in front of a
car but what if they're a comedy account
and they have 42 funny ideas every day
then you should save them and spread
them out because you'll run out okay no
taken yeah so so far this website has
been able to detect political bots
mainly let me know what their yeah
that's where they should be
now the question is why hasn't Twitter
adopted them yet yeah right so that's
that's what I think is kind of fishy
like maybe there keeps them alive this
kind of sturgeon a fake news is exciting
that's how they get retweets that's how
they get people to talk about their [ __ ]
unless these two guys are [ __ ]
annoying as [ __ ] so they could have set
up a meeting or whatever and like hey we
got the best technology oh come on down
we're gonna have a meeting talked about
this and usually gonna go play golf or
your drink or sing karaoke and then
business partners they they get cool
with each other but in these fools are
just [ __ ] dicks and no I don't give a
[ __ ] what you're selling Europe you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I agree that has happened many many
times feel like recently like with an
only leg within the last two years like
the like going Twitter viral has become
a thing oh yes this was not a thing like
just like a handful of years ago people
just tweeted and I was it no one ever
favorited no one no one really like
retweeted stuff and you know what it is
because of the thread aspect I think
because then you can see how people are
responding I don't think they had that
before that yeah yeah people go like
Twitter viral it's kind of like your
Twitter famous now yeah people get
Twitter famous I want to be Twitter I
need to get back on sweater also has
fake news a lot face of books oh yeah
but they're actually been trying they're
trying to crack down do you guys ever
get like read the comments on like your
YouTube and it's like it's a really
really racist or just terrible thing and
then you look at their like name and
it's like oh of course you would have
that name like it's always like our
negative comments are always from like
some guy with like American Eagle flag
or like a skull face mess and like white
angel xxx or something like that's
always from ladies but it might it might
be a troll - it might time to make there
might be someone that's not even white
that's doing that to come in and that's
a lot of effort that's that happens
though dude what they do not happen I
got an argument with the with the Asian
girl but it was a [ __ ] troll she
wasn't even Asian how did you find out
because people were like that's a troll
dude and I looked into it I was like oh
my god you can't feed him you [ __ ]
like the only time I will respond to
somebody who's very David you respond
right I respond all the time but that's
usually because I'm taking a [ __ ] so I I
literally have to be doing nothing yeah
then it's like alright yeah
and I think the cool thing is is like
how they feed off it is because they
think you're actually
yeah for me it's like I'm taking a
Dookie you know and I'll go if you guys
know if you guys got tweeted back from
David he was [ __ ] on you but not
what I'm doing now is this debt is that
when I started to realize was because I
started doing that for fun but people
are leaving positive comments and I'm
not saying anything to them so now I'm
doing the opposite it's like okay well
the people who are saying nice things or
they want to actually feed the nice ones
yeah idiots get all the attention
yes I'm saying so I just blocked them
yeah if Charles have the the title
trolls what would you give the non
trolls lovers no oh I was gonna wait
wait I was gonna oh wait wait moles
angels doesn't sound like trolls you
know what I was thinking cause there's
bachelors but then there's like the fun
trolls to like Justin Timberlake true
Green is a fun troll would it be he's a
treasure troll I hated those thing
treasure troll what for trolls again
things with the crazy hair oh yeah I
thought your thing is so you're saying
glory hole oh he's still a man what wait
but glory holes are very very disgusting
yeah it's like the bad side of cards
niche market outside you know I'm trying
to be like what if like what if it was
like like there's actually something
that's it's a mistaken for something
else like it's what glory glorious like
you you for church you go there for like
that's where you put your it's a glory
trough that's that's what you put your
your your your dick in a pew in a Bible
oh my god what am I saying yeah you're
offering you put it your dick in the
offering plane like it's jacks it off on
the other side there's an offering box
there's a whole this armor box as a
whole and you're putting in the offering
because you want glory to happen so you
know the glory hole take a weird turn if
you're in a bathroom and there's a
cutout for a glory hole is that because
you want your dick sucked by another guy
because there's no unisex one it's
supposed to be the wall that you share
with the lady's bathroom is
oh really I thought it was two guys well
I don't know wait I thought you look
through oh that's a that's a people oh
yeah the sweetest thing she got a dick
in her eyes she has you're right I was
think of a peephole guys but it's a sure
sure I don't know any dick that can go
past the drywall but if it does make it
through the other side of your desert
yeah you deserve it too oh we're just
trying to think of the other opposite
Patrol yeah Laurie hole I like the glory
hole glory angel I like glory Hall glory
oh it is to all of our glory halls
thank you very much
[Music]